Which needles should be out of work?
By default, knitting machines position
stitch patterns in the center
of the needle bed.
Electronic machines allow us to move
the position of stitch
patterns on the needle bed.
But for this conversation,
we're looking at stitch patterns
being centered on the needle bed.
There are a number of ways to determine
what needles need to be out of work.
First, study the pattern.
Many of our pattern books,
like the Stitch World books,
will display stitch diagrams with the
needle out of work looking like this.
Keep in mind that the pattern is centered
on the needle bed,
so draw a line down the center
of the diagram and the O
indicates needles out of work.
If there are an odd number of stitches
in the stitch multiple,
put the extra stitch on the left.
In this example, needles number left
3 and right 2 will be out of work.
Number 2, study the punch card.
This time draw a line down the center
of the punch card
and look for holes and no holes.
Remember, holes mean needles are knitting
and no holes are stitches
that are going to be tucked.
Now, we don't want to tuck
two stitches side by side.
So in this example, there are full columns
of no holes, which indicate that these
should be needles out of work.
Put the needles out of work and these
stitches will tuck next to those needles out of work.
In this example,
there are columns of holes.
And what if you put these needles out
of work and let these stitches tuck?
Number three, the best way to determine
needle positions is by testing
the stitch pattern.
On Brother machine's preselect needles,
so we can do a dry run without yarn to
establish what needles will be tucking.
In this example, we can see that needle
number one right is tucking for two rows,
and then needle number one
left is tucking for two rows.
According to our diagram,
we want needles out of work next
to the needles that are tucking.
There'll be two needles out of work.
So I'll set up my needle bed,
two needles out of work, two needles in,
two needles out, two needles in.
On Silver's, singer, studio machines,
we can test by knitting a little bit
of tuck and observing
which needles are tucking.
We'll cast on with some waste yarn
and knit a few rows,
then engage the punch card or electronics
and knit across the first row,
noting which needles tuck,
knit a few more rows,
watching the tuck sequence,
and note which needles are tucking.
Now, for this stitch pattern,
we want needles out of work
next to the tuck stitches.
Now that we've identified the tuck
needles, we can put the correct
needles out of work. With
the needles arranged correctly,
you can now test knit that tuck
lace with your scrap yarn.
Here's a tip.
Take a photo of your needle bed to record
the needle arrangement and keep it
with your punch card or keep a record
for the next time you want
to use this stitch pattern.
For manual machines,
you'll follow a stitch diagram.
I suggest creating a cheat sheet to follow
to know when to manually put needles
in hold for the tuck stitches.
If you use DesignaKnit,
use the interactive knitting feature
to identify the position
of the needles out of work.
Here's a tip.
No matter what machine you're using,
if you create your stitch pattern
in DesignaKnit,
choosing the knitting method right side
facing or wrong side facing impacts how
the stitch pattern is
positioned on the needle bed.
So be aware of this if you don't use
Interactive Knitting and you use
DesignaKnit to create punch cards.